hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for a Monday
January 9
2023. what's going on Hawaii
how's it going everybody I hope you're
having a wonderful 2023 so far I hope
you count your blessings
I hope you're just holding everybody you
know near and dear
and all that other filler
that people say right they're all
[ __ ] uh you know
just filling it up with the old filler
up you know
just saying what you suppose thoughts
and prayers go out to the [ __ ] uh
something see fun and uh you know
win one for the Gipper or whatever the
[ __ ] you're supposed to say nowadays you
just you just uh
you just say nice things
I hope the sun shines down on your part
of the world and when it does you take
in the Rays and just realized that
the sun's always out you know
tomorrow
Sun Will Come Out Tomorrow
bet that sign in the window won't change
society but you tried
you wrote your political opinion not a
piece of paper you stuck it in the
window cause you're self-involved and
you think people care
but they do not give a [ __ ] what you
think their parents already filled their
heads
all right there you go I'm working on a
new musical
you know I'm sampling Annie I'm not
stealing all right I feel like I have
the right consider I'm also with ginger
you know I love how Orphan Annie was a
[ __ ] redhead of course they kicked to
the curb the second they saw her coming
out with that [ __ ] right the lights on
you know
I got brown here you got black hair what
in the [ __ ] is this
no I mean it's just you know a couple
Generations back you put that thing down
the goddamn orphanage we're gonna try
again all right it's a stretch your
[ __ ] legs woman
you dump that package off you come back
and we're going to get back to [ __ ]
you understand me that's the prequel
to Annie that I have been shopping
around Hollywood for years and no one
wants to hear it you know
and I'm I'm calling reverse sexism
um actually I was gonna sell the idea
but then they were like but are you the
right person at this time to direct it
and I was like well I am a ginger and
they said yeah but it all fell out and I
said fair enough
and they said are you willing to give
this
idea turn it over
to a full-headed hair Ginger
and I just couldn't pull the trigger I
said no I am not
I'm too close to the project
and they said great you're now going to
be escorted off of this lot and I have
not worked since
okay but am I bitter whatever
anyway what was I talking about oh
selling a musical
selling a goddamn musical that's one of
the hardest things you can ever do
especially
you know not because the themes are hard
it's the fact that I'm tone deaf
you know other than that when you look
at a musical
when you see the subject matter for 90
of them
I think a lot of them is you just take
like a an album
you know that was popular and you just
feel like all right how can I turn that
into a musical
you know like uh Bat Out of Hell the
musical
they did it with um
they did it with uh
uh Abba
right
do they do with Bob Seger yet
do they have Against the Wind the
musical
I don't know what they did
I'm not up on that [ __ ] I'm not up on
that [ __ ] the way I'm not up on the
[ __ ] NFL Jesus [ __ ] Christ I got
my goddamn ass handed to me from
December on
it's kind of what happens when you
gamble on football and you watch like
one game every three weeks
I had to pick five games this week
because the Bengals and the bills got
canceled because of that poor kid you
know all that stuff that happened which
I'm sure you heard about and I guess
he's sitting up he's talking and
everything's great right so I bet the
Patriots this week
I bet the Patriots I bet with my [ __ ]
hat right rather than my brains
all right but you know our offense has
been coming along you know it's not as
anemic as it was
you know what defense has been great all
year I mean you know just when you spend
90 percent of the time on the [ __ ]
field you know shit's gonna happen right
so anyway it was one of those deals
where it was weird before the game you
know because of the tragedy the week
before I was having this weird thing
where I was like I can't root against
the bills it reminded me of like when
the Yankees went to the World Series
after 9 11 I was just like I can't
[ __ ] root against these guys I'm not
gonna root for him the best I can do is
I'm not going to root against them and
it didn't didn't hurt that they were
playing the Arizona
uh Diamondbacks
all right like who gives a [ __ ] about
that team was an expansion team
you're right there were yet another team
that I believe stole the Yankees
pinstripe so I was kind of like [ __ ]
them and then they also had like a
Jacuzzi out in the Outfield it's like
these people don't give a [ __ ]
like what what are we doing here
I'll go as far as saying this if you
have a Jacuzzi you're a [ __ ] dirtbag
you know what I mean I'm not talking
about if it's attached to a pool I'll
look the other way but if all you have
is a standalone jacuzzi
you're at least dealing weed but now
that's legal
I don't know back when I was growing up
you know
there was a person with a certain kind
of car
right a Monte Carlo T-tops
right an old Cutlass detox
a Grand Prix T-tops
right
money SS
detox
and what came with the t-tops a [ __ ]
hot tub you had a [ __ ] hot tub
right you had broads over there [ __ ] was
there was drugs
it was drugs I would love
for them to drain every hot tub
in this [ __ ] country that was from
the 80s and then run a black light over
it and how much semen and cocaine that
you would find at the bottom of those
goddamn things
I think there's enough freestanding Coke
in those [ __ ] Waters that if you
could somehow sift it which I believe
they have the technology
okay I believe the Freemasons know how
to [ __ ] do it if they could [ __ ]
sift all the goddamn cocaine out of the
bottom of those hot tubs
and sell it back to [ __ ] uh
what the [ __ ] does it come from Colombia
we could knock down this goddamn debt
we could maybe
have enough money
to start another War right
I'm not up on politics people but you
know the other day
I just feel like the level of [ __ ]
the level of corruption
on all levels you know people look at it
in politics you know tonight in Lost
flangalese
January 9th
2000 and [ __ ]
uh what do you call it two thousand and
[ __ ] 23.
they're having the NCAA
I almost didn't say that right the NCAA
football championship
why can't I speak NCAA Football
Championship tonight against TCU come on
frogs right all those J.R Ewing looking
line dancing sons of [ __ ] who look
like they're gonna go do a guest star on
[ __ ] Yellowstone
right
how great is [ __ ] Yellowstone and I
got the Harrison Ford prequel
who knew
you know there was all this money
in [ __ ] Cowboys
the Western is coming they finally
updated it I guess the Harrison Ford
ones is from back in the 20s they
finally got the cowboy out of the 1800s
right and now they got him in the 2000s
these are actual Cowboys these guys are
on [ __ ] horses I'm talking about real
cowboys I'm not talking about people in
Texas that wear a cowboy hat and drive a
shiny pickup truck that never leaves the
road unless there's traffic and you're
cutting across the medium to that local
[ __ ] road which is the move in Texas
I learned that pretty quickly
um I'm talking about real cowboys
all right
ones that are out there you know with a
guitar
you know mend an offense
whatever it is they do
you know they're like a dormant volcano
aren't they
there's no Buffalo left
you know they've corralled all the
indigenous people I mean what is a
cowboy supposed to do now
they're sort of the blacksmith of uh
of 2023
I don't I you know I don't know I've
never watched a real estate show from
Wyoming so I really don't know what's
going on in that part of the world but
you know I'm trying
anyway so this is the kind of the
corruption that I'm talking about this
is what I'm trying to talk about I'm
talking in circles here but stay with me
I'm losing altitude I'm gonna hit the
ground soon to just [ __ ] just stay
with me here
um
down at Sofi Stadium they have in the
Super Bowl college football and do you
know that they're saying you're not
allowed to tailgate
you're not allowed to tailgate what the
[ __ ] you [ __ ] mean I'm not allowed to
tailgate tailgating comes with the
[ __ ] ticket
is this going to be the new thing you're
not allowed to tailgate are you trying
to force me into the stadium
to pay those astronomical prices for all
of that [ __ ] [ __ ] food you know it's
not my fault you decided to [ __ ]
build a flying saucer and bury it
[ __ ] nine miles into the goddamn
ground
I didn't ask for that [ __ ] stay I was
fine with LA Memorial Coliseum I didn't
see a [ __ ] problem with it
all these soft [ __ ] saying it was a
dump you God damn right it's a dump it's
a [ __ ] Stadium what's the matter
there's no luxury boxes They don't serve
sushi what the [ __ ] are you here for
they don't have a hot tub on one end of
the [ __ ] goddamn uh their little
[ __ ] herpes aquarium down there that
that's what's missing for you
huh oh look at me I got my [ __ ] legs
crossed and I got a foot going around in
a circle right now I really think I'm
making a point here they're saying that
you can't [ __ ] tailgate
I would love to see them enforce that
you can tell people from Georgia they
can't tailgate
I mean most people from Georgia live
outside once you get outside of Atlanta
I mean it is just it's a [ __ ]
free-for-all
huh
that's that's Charlie Daniels
country out there
I get stoned in the morning get drunk in
the afternoon
I ain't asking nobody for nothing
if I can't get it oh my own one of my
favorite [ __ ] country songs
right I related to it
I was a loner I didn't like being around
people now I'm gonna go live in a
[ __ ] swamp
you know
and even when I had hair I couldn't grow
it long if I [ __ ] wanted to I
couldn't
you know
my head and broke down it [ __ ] grew
out
just yet another [ __ ] reason yet
another [ __ ] reason to feel like a
weirdo and to put on a Charlie Daniels
song and be like I [ __ ] like this guy
you can tell people from from from from
from Texas that they can't [ __ ] do
something
you want somebody from Texas to not do
something tell them that they can do it
they'll sit on their [ __ ] asses and
they won't do [ __ ] tell them they can't
[ __ ] do it
right and all of a sudden they got their
Spurs on
right putting on a goddamn belt buckle
with a gun on the side of it
that's their deal right you know [ __ ]
like that
if you want them to go left you got to
tell them to go right
I don't understand that well Don't Mess
with Texas all of that [ __ ] they just
they're looking for it they're bored
that whole state is a bunch of cowboys
with no one left to kill right
okay
I'm sorry
I'm in a weird [ __ ] mood you know
somebody uh posted on Instagram
listen to this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that you'll never that they they want to
I don't know if this is true or not it
said members of Congress outperformed
the stock market for the second year in
a row in 2022 with lawmakers reporting
nearly 800 million in total assets
and more than twelve thousand seven
hundred trades despite one of the worst
markets since 2008. lawmakers in both
parties fared better than the s p 500.
isn't that incredible
I mean I mean dick addiction it over
there
I don't know why they don't get on bed
MGM
they could [ __ ] pick a football game
better than I could
unbelievable shout out to Democrats and
Republicans
I mean all the rest of us are getting
our pockets turned inside now you know I
can't get mad at them it's it's it's
almost as though
they have inside information
damn
we'll not go investigate it what so
[ __ ] ever
right however some regular person does
some regular [ __ ] right and all of a
sudden they're in trouble
you know
I don't know what I'm trying to say here
it's just like can't you just let people
go to the game and [ __ ] tailgate I
mean it's gonna rain anyway you know
the amount of people driving across the
country spend all their money on their
goddamn ticket and they're going to get
out there and they got their [ __ ] TVs
their tents and all this [ __ ] and
they're ready for the rain and all of
that crap and they're ready to tailgate
and you're gonna come by in your golf
cart and say
get in the stadium and overpay for what
you already have in your cooler
I mean
this is the bread and circus this is
sports this is the only thing we have
left you're going to start [ __ ] with
that like how much [ __ ] money do
these [ __ ] need to make it's it's
unbelievable
the level of upset that I am about that
tailgate and what the House
Representatives and the Senators doing
and this is the funny thing I haven't
investigated either one of those facts
for all I know you can tailgate somebody
just told me that you can't and I said
what the [ __ ] and that was it
somebody posted something on Instagram I
read it and I said that is true
and here I am talking about and there
you sit listening to it
huh this is how
it [ __ ] starts
um
I've started this podcast like nine
times so I can't even what the [ __ ] I
talked to I've been talking about did I
mention how bad I got my [ __ ] ass
kicked on these goddamn picks
I started to talk about the uh the Bills
game
right so I'm sitting there going like
all right well I ca I can't root against
these guys I was already rooting for the
bills this year anyway you know
I remember when they lost the four Super
Bowls in a row I remember when that
[ __ ] [ __ ] was in the crease it's
just you know I saw they got six feet of
[ __ ] snow in like 20 minutes it's
just like when is God gonna let these
people [ __ ] stand upright
so I've been rooting for the bill I
rooted for him last year I'm rooting for
this year it's funny because they hate
the Patriots and I could give a [ __ ]
about the bills I don't give a [ __ ] if
you win it I hope you win it
you know
maybe you guys can afford to actually go
buy some pants instead of those [ __ ]
I don't know zebra Buffalo Bills stripe
[ __ ] uh puffy pants you're wearing
from 30 [ __ ] years ago
right I'm rooting for you guys right so
the goddamn game starts
all right
we win the toss
we give it over the bills
we kick it off to him and lo and behold
the guy takes it back the 50 the 40.
both announcers whoever the other guy is
and Tony Romo I call him Anthony right
Andy Romo they [ __ ] lose their [ __ ]
oh my God it's like a fairy tale
right and Tony Romo kept saying this
thing that made me feel s really stupid
um I love Tony Romo a guy [ __ ] knows
the game he predicts what's gonna happen
it's fascinating to listen to a game he
called but he just kept saying after the
bill scored that touchdown
he kept saying it's almost fate
and the other guy was so busy go it was
like a dream it was like Tinkerbell
landed on my nose and touched him with
and he just kept saying it was almost
fake it's almost fake and I'm thinking
like what the [ __ ] does that mean
what is almost fake that that poor kid
was gonna have a heart attack
so everybody could be sad collectively
in root for him so they could run a
kickback against that [ __ ] Terrible
Special Teams
is that what he was saying
I don't know what he was saying but he
kind of alligator armed it because he
said it was almost fake
can somebody please explain that because
I know that I'm here that I don't
understand I I do know that
I don't know much but I know I guess I
don't know what [ __ ] fate means
it's almost fate uh Jesus Christ so then
they're all doing you know the heart
with the number three
you know and that starts getting
annoying and I had to keep reminding
myself like Bill a guy almost died
okay can you stop rooting for [ __ ]
uniforms for five goddamn seconds
so then we came back
you know and we scored a touchdown at
seven to seven I'm like that's it right
I yell break their hearts and I was like
bad reference
ruined their football Sunday
[Laughter]
so then the bills go back down
and uh by the way you know [ __ ] Josh
Allen and just amazing quarterback that
back shoulder passed the [ __ ] Stefan
Diggs you know I mean it's just amazing
I love
watching him play and uh I feel like
he's a smoother Ben Roethlisberger
same big guy tough guy hard to break
down same type of thing but this guy is
like more
[ __ ] precise where I feel like
Roethlisberger was like a gunslinger
this kid is like fundamentally [ __ ]
sound and I don't want to jinx anything
out there but I think that that kid is
gonna uh you know
he's gonna get some jewelry at some
point okay and he's not going to Jacob
the Jeweler
I think he's going to get it from the
NFL not trying to jinx anything I think
he's [ __ ] great
so he throws it you know
too much time he throws a [ __ ]
touchdown and the second touchdown
whoever that guy was that scored it
looked into the camera dreamy-eyed and
made the heart thing and did the number
three and he was so staring into the
camera it made me uncomfortable
all right and then up there so then what
do I do I really start rooting for the
Patriots at this point okay because I'm
just sitting there going like I
understand there's a tragedy we're
obviously rooting for the kid the kid is
sitting up he's talking he's gonna be
back he's gonna be better than ever [ __ ]
the bills right now let's [ __ ] go
pets I got money on the game right just
being a total selfish bald freckled [ __ ]
and I just had the [ __ ] game gets
away from us
gets away from us congratulations to the
bills the Patriots are going home we get
a draft pick you know we get we get
something in the gift bag
we'll see what happens maybe hopefully
we'll get a [ __ ] receiver
um
I don't know who made the playoffs all I
know is that I had to pick five games
this week because I had money uh last
week on the [ __ ] bills
and Bengals they obviously canceled that
game and somehow that [ __ ] the Bengals
I don't know how that happened
you know but they were doing some sort
of flipping the coin thing
um
when Mixon ran in I believe
um this is this is my dumbass picks and
I'll tell you right now if you listen to
me on the anything better podcast if you
haven't figured out yet to just bet
against if you bet against everything
that I said this week you absolutely
destroyed it I took the Pats with the
points
lost my ass I took the [ __ ] Raiders
okay against the Kansas City Chiefs I'm
thinking like all right it's a division
rivalry game you know they're getting 14
points Brady's got a great defense
you know they got some good receivers
and [ __ ] they'll keep it it's not gonna
lose by [ __ ] four even that down by
14. they'll go into a prevent defense
even though the Chiefs don't really do
that
I learned that the hard way a couple
months ago uh you know I think they'll
be able to keep they got the [ __ ]
[ __ ] kicked out of them
the absolute [ __ ] kicked out of him
I picked the Ravens over the Bengals I
mean that [ __ ] game was over before
it started another little Ravens came
back and made it close I lost that one
I took the [ __ ] Cardinals
you know
I'm thinking uh
Colt McCoy best backup in the league
he's getting 14 points division rivalry
people are playing for their jobs as JJ
Watts possibly his last game the great
JJ Watt they're going to come out there
and [ __ ] at least keep it close got
this [ __ ] kicked out of him
I don't even know who my last I think my
last game that I take Seattle
I don't know who the [ __ ] I took
I don't know who I took but I can tell
you right now uh
I should be banned from gambling on
football
that's all I'm saying
um
so anyway
I uh
there's some buddies of mine are in town
right
and um
I ended up uh
hanging out today I played golf again
I played nine holes
and I'm actually getting better at it
it's [ __ ] annoying me because I'm
trying not to give a [ __ ] and I actually
for the first time kept score
and I shot a 49
on nine holes
so if I kept that up I would have broke
a hundred
which to me
kind of
is what I've always been saying that
golf is not nearly
as difficult
as people say it's just
you know there's so many non-athletes
that play it I'm obviously saying at a
[ __ ] high level to break 80 I mean
you got to be [ __ ] athletic you got
to play I'm not disrespecting the game
at that I'm just talking about all of
these [ __ ] hacks out there
I mean the body types
the fact that it's considered a sport
and you just look at some of these
[ __ ] people just rolling out of their
cars with their stupid outfits on
going over there hitting this [ __ ]
you know it's like it's like t-ball
right
and uh and they go out there and they
affect the Curve
the grading curve about how [ __ ]
difficult this goddamn game is
so um
anyway but I'm still doing what I always
do I refuse to buy clubs
and I've been playing with the same ball
for the last 27 holds a title is four
the title is four lives
I thought I lost it today I hit a tree
and it bounced back out I [ __ ]
part the last hole
and uh
it's funny one of the guys I was golfing
with
because I was like what hole are we on
and he goes uh
we're on the seventh hole he goes I
always get sad you know
because it's almost over and I'm
thinking in my head like I always get
psyched because I'm usually bored
shitless by the [ __ ] fourth hole
oh my God
the [ __ ] Pomp and Circumstance around
when you're just standing there waiting
for someone to hit the ball fortunately
people I was playing with were playing
fast
is there anything [ __ ] worse than
just watching somebody addressing the
ball
for like 28 [ __ ] seconds it feels
like you're standing there for 10
minutes and then just to watch them
[ __ ] hook it or slice it
and they always put that hand up like
like it wasn't them who hit it like
there was something else wrong like when
somebody cuts you off and [ __ ] causes
an accident and then they immediately go
like what the [ __ ] it's like what do you
mean what the [ __ ] he ran the light you
[ __ ]
right
you don't get to go what the [ __ ] you're
in the wrong right but people
immediately they start posting up with
like what the [ __ ]
um
it's kind of funny like watching the
level of people everybody goes like Ryan
Leaf out there
they start losing their [ __ ] and people
throw clubs and they break them and they
throw them in the [ __ ] water
it's [ __ ] hilarious
he's like what are you mad at
you know what's funny about golf is you
can't get mad
at anybody else is because you did it
so then what do people do then they get
mad at the game they get mad at their
clubs they start blaming [ __ ] that
[ __ ] a goddamn bird flu it's like
dude
you suck
okay nobody picked you in gym class
stop acting like you're athletic
this is not a sport
it just isn't
that's why you're out here
okay
do you ever play in a pickup League of
basketball pick up League of hockey you
haven't played flight you didn't do any
of that [ __ ]
because you suck
can you throw a ball can you catch no
you can't
because you suck so why would you think
that you would come out here
right and not suck
huh
sorry
anyway
the only game I like to [ __ ] on more
than soccer is golf
I actually like soccer it's just
it's just it's part of being an American
to thumb your nose with the re at the
rest of the world when they're all
obeying the Paris treaty and [ __ ]
losing their mind about with their
version of football
for you to just sit there and be like no
[ __ ] the Paris treaty
[ __ ] your version of football and and
and we're and and [ __ ] the metric system
which probably admittedly you know if I
was more mature were three huge mistakes
that this country made
but England can't get mad because you
can't still drive on the opposite side
of the road just to be [ __ ] [ __ ] so
you you relate to it and at the end of
the day we we are you guys
don't act like we fell out of the sky
okay we we came from your goddamn
country
are we smart enough to leave we saw
those taxes coming and God knows now
they're happening over here
um
when I flew a passenger this week
helicopter first time I flew blood
somewhere from a family
that was [ __ ] stressful as [ __ ] I was
just up there thinking about all the
people that'd be [ __ ] mad at me
and then we ended up having a great time
or whatever so
um it's kind of my goal this year is to
get uh
get way more solo hours and that type of
stuff and I'm having a great time with
it
um
anyway oh Jesus Christ people [ __ ]
calling me here
see if I can get through this podcast
without another goddamn Interruption and
I went to a restaurant today
and I went into the bathroom
and I go in there and there's a guy in
there with his son who's young so he
needs like help so immediately it's like
[ __ ] weird you know when you walk in
there and there's a dad helping his kid
go to the bathroom so all I had to do
was take a piss but you know
respectfully I went to a stall rather
than being at the urinal because he was
you know
helping the kid wash his hands and [ __ ]
so I go in the goddamn [ __ ] bathroom
just whoo
I'm talking about side of the road in
the middle of nowhere at gas station
bathroom smell like what the [ __ ]
this is bad and there was a trash barrel
right next to the toilet I'm gonna tell
you right now it's gross and there was
toilet paper and I wasn't really
thinking about it I'm just like taking a
piss or whatever
and then right as I'm almost done taking
a piss I looked down and I see the
toilet rock paper has skid marks on it
I almost puked
like what in the [ __ ]
and it was like an office trash can so
it was like see-through so even if you
weren't looking down into it from the
side you could see it there's a [ __ ]
it's just one of those things you see
and you're just not the same person
after it I want that father and son left
I got to the sink and I was like gagging
like I and like it takes a lot
you know and that was enough and I was
just like oh my God I gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here and I didn't tell the other
people I was eating with what happened
until after we left and I was like I
don't think I'm gonna go back to that
place like I don't know what the [ __ ]
that was
I mean I felt like I was in another
country like what is that
you know it's like looking at an outlet
in Europe the first time you go over
you're like what what is this can I
stick my thing in there it [ __ ] blows
up your laptop you're like okay
evidently not
um
oh you know what's funny was when we
were golfing
there was this dual engine helicopter
just like flying super slow
over this Canyon and then it just came
to a stop
and everybody's going like
you know was asking me like I know
everything about helicopters like what
are they doing I was like I think
somebody fell
hiking
so I was waiting for the [ __ ] rope
with the goddamn bed
to come down it never did so they must
have had some people on the ground being
like all right he's all right you know
and I just started laughing because I
was thinking it was probably somebody
some poor bastard like New Year's
resolution I'm gonna start [ __ ]
walking more get more exercise I'm gonna
turn around
and they just crushed it for [ __ ]
eight days
and the next day you know you just
laying on your back trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] happened to you
you know like you had your head down in
hockey next thing you know it was a
helicopter hovering over and you're like
oh my God am I that guy
I'm that guy I can't go on a goddamn
hike without getting [ __ ] airlifted
out
what a shameful [ __ ] moment that's
gotta be
that almost happened to me when I I told
that story before when I was in [ __ ]
Colorado
and we where the [ __ ] were we Colorado
Springs I just told this story because I
just performed there
I was hiking in in the beginnings of the
Rocky Mountains I think like right there
right off the what is that that 25
just uh west of that
I was hiking with somebody else and I I
was standing up on this rock and two
seconds later I was not
I [ __ ] went down like a ton I didn't
I still don't even know it was dry out I
don't know what I slipped on but how I
didn't break my FEMA or my humerus and I
would have been that guy
you know
underrated going on a hike and not
having to be airlifted out of there
uh by the way if you guys uh you guys
been sending in some great emails so I'm
going to do the uh
you know please remind listeners of the
podcast email if you would like to write
into this podcast
and hear me try and read your [ __ ] out
loud uh go to Monday morning podcast at
gmail.com
uh that's the way you want to do it and
uh anyway so I came back from drumming
and uh drumming came back from playing
golf
and I sat down and wailed on the kit for
a minute
had a good time and then I just played
with my kids I was playing uh playing
catch with them
in the living room when we play this
game called double throw
where both people have a ball and you go
one two three and you gotta throw it at
the same time my daughter's getting so
good at it
you know we're trying to see if we could
get up to 20 in a row first
she like legit beat me
20 to 19. [ __ ] choked on the last one
slash she didn't give me the best
[ __ ] throw
um and my son's coming along catching
you know I think that's a big thing you
know
teaching kids how to throw and catch and
how to drive a stick shift I know I'm an
old dad but that's like important to me
so
that's going to happen anyway uh
congratulations to everybody that made
the playoffs I am rooting for the bills
I've been rooting for him all year I'm
not bandwagon because of uh
that horrible thing that happened last
week which seems like it's going to be
all right you know what's funny at the
beginning of the game did you see how
they showed
all of those people that [ __ ] just
responded perfectly to it
and the NFL is showing footage of it
that was another thing that I didn't buy
you know
I buy all of those people and how great
they are at the job but I feel like the
NFL was showing that to uh prevent any
sort of a lawsuit just to have let's
have this on camera
all 15 of these people had a job to do
and they crushed it let's make sure this
is on camera [ __ ] the sidelines on any
goddamn catch we don't need to cover
that let's just cover our asses
um all right I'm cynical okay rocket
money everybody
you know
if your New Year's goal goals are to
manage your budget better and save money
you need rocket money
say goodbye to last year's outdated
disorganized methods of managing your
money and say hello to Rocket money I
wonder if they use that in the House of
Representatives Jesus Christ uh the the
better way to hack your finances in 2023
uh rocket money formerly known as true
bill is a personal finance app that
finds and cancels oh my God you're
canceled your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place this
thing is great over 80 percent of people
have subscriptions that they forgot
about talking about me like that
streaming service you bought to watch
just one show on yeah like when I
[ __ ] signed up for Nessun and they
took my money and then they're like yeah
we don't broadcast out there
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh I never got that money
back or that free trial that you never
even used rocket money will quickly and
easily identify your subscriptions for
you so you can can stop paying for the
ones you don't want rocket money makes
canceling subscriptions as easy as a
click of a button simply find the
subscription you don't want and press
cancel
see this is this is for [ __ ] old
people like me I don't have to [ __ ]
go to my systems
what do they always say uh click on your
something systems and then you're like I
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ] anyway and Rocket
money will cancel it for you no more
long hold times with customer service or
tedious emailing back and forth over
three million people have used rocket
money saving the average person 720 a
year
it's probably the average amount of
money somebody's going to spend on
concessions at the [ __ ] Sofi Stadium
tomorrow stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com that's rocketmoney.com
rocketmoney.com
uh all the code is everybody indochi no
you know if you rang in the new year
with someone special in 2023 you will be
uh a new chapter in your relationship in
nochino is ready to help you look your
best on your big day with their huge
variety of customizable details and
fabrics indochino can help you create
anything from made to measure Blazers
and Suits to a custom
portrait worthy tuxedo all with no
tailor necessary indochino gives you
everything you need to create a custom
suit that's right for you shop online by
settling setting up your measurements
profile and choosing the fabric and
customizations you want uh prefer an
in-person experience no problem book an
appointment at an indochino showroom and
work with an expert style guide to take
your measurements and walk you through
your customization options then just sit
back while your suit is made for you and
delivered straight to your door
indochino is a tailored experience at a
great price design a look that suits you
perfectly from the fabric to cut start
suit start at uh just 4.99 in premium
fitted shirts start at just 89
you can fine tune every detail lapels
Linings Monograms like an old school man
right and more if you're ringing in 2023
with Wedding Bells ahead start planning
your custom look with indochino that's
the way to go right there save some
[ __ ] money on that day go to
indochino.com and use Burr to get 10 off
any purchase of 3.99 or more that's i n
d o c h i n o.com promo code Burr
oh here's a new one look at this I got a
new Advertiser here Grove
have some resolutions
uh what have some resolutions to be more
sustainable
make it easy and start with eliminating
single-use Plastics oh I'm all for any
of this type of stuff Grove
collaborative is here with reusable
swaps to make a lasting impact at your
home for your family and the planet
uh
um a new year means a fresh start and a
chance to change the way you care for
the planet now is the perfect time to
take your home to make your home
healthier happier and more sustainable
discover everything you need for a
sustainable home at Grove collaborative
a new year means new commitments to
those we care about family and Planet
included if you've been waiting to make
your sustainable choices for Home Care
Beauty and more start with Grove
collaborative ready to make 23 2023 uh
the best year yet for your family and
the planet start a sustainable
Revolution at the home with at home with
Grove collaborative and Shop over 150
brands that make a real impact sorry
this is new copy so I'm going to be a
little bad on this one uh Grove carries
hundreds of products aimed at replacing
single-use Plastics across your home and
personal care routine and by 2025 Grove
will be 100 plastic free amazing uh like
micros come see I like seeing [ __ ] like
this this gives me hope
you know that young people will have a a
nice clean world that they can live in
hopefully uh light Grove companies
concentrated cleaners and refillable
glass bottles they're friendlier to the
planet and twice as effective as the
leading natural Brands switch to
sustainable products for every room in
your home from laundry care to hand
soaps and more Grove company has you
covered with safe formulas and
refillable packaging that never
compromise on performance join over 2
million households already shopping
sustainably at Grove go to grove.com
today to get a starter set worth up to
fifty dollars with your first order plus
shipping is fast and free uh get started
right now at grove.com grove.com
uh funny English oh whoops
funny English chance this is the first
read for the week
um
by the by the people writing in
um okay what do we got here funny
English chants
all right I asked people that uh uh you
know
that watch soccer
as we call it here in America or
football
as they call it in the rest of the world
and being an American I still feel we're
right
uh they have these hilarious songs that
they sing during the game so I wanted
people to send some in uh please keep
these coming because they're great so
funny English chants hey there bald
baffled butter Billy boy this funny
chant originated in a non-league club
called FC United of Manchester not the
famous man united it is sung to the by
the tune of the Anna Adams Family song
the lyrics are your sister is your
mother your father is your brother you
all [ __ ] one another the Katie family
clap clap clap clap it's amazing here's
the link you guys want to hear them
singing it's kind of interesting because
it's in it's it stays in 4-4 I believe
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I just like how they speed up that one
part I was counting it out it's still in
four they're just going to like double
time
it's like The Lemon Song
um
your sister is your mother your father
is your brother you're all for one
another
the Katy family
I'm just like that you can [ __ ] sing
something like that
and there's no DJ drowning you out
Jesus Christ if I have one more DJ go
make some noise yeah why don't you shut
the [ __ ] up and we will
we don't need you
um or maybe they do that's my New Year's
resolution I gotta stop bitching about
modern sports because I'll be honest
with you my criticism in the NBA is is
not right okay I watched the game the
other night it wasn't what I was saying
there wasn't a you know
it was actually an entertaining game I'm
just a [ __ ]
I'm just a [ __ ] yes I'm only a [ __ ] and
I'm acting like a [ __ ] damn [ __ ] and
I say that the [ __ ] ladies are better
than now and give you no examples
of [ __ ] hell
but it doesn't stop me from bitching how
I hope and pray okay by request on the
last episode English soccer fight songs
hello Billy Babylon
uh you requested English soccer
parentheses not real football songs that
would rival the Michigan fight song this
is certainly not one of them
um
well I don't know how to sing this so I
guess I'll just read it I'll read it
first and then I'll play it a few years
ago I drank 10 pints of more
and I think that was supposed to be 10
pints or more and add a horrific
hangover so I looked up online if other
people
of if other people drinking as many
pints of course the English do and I'm
apparently descended from them as I've
done the genetic test and can no longer
be a serial killer as my DNA is in the
worldwide database
um do you think anybody just got a
creepy vibe from an uncle or something
like that
you know
that's a good way to keep a creepy Uncle
away from you go get a [ __ ] DNA check
have the cops pick them up before he
takes you air quote takes you to a game
uh the chorus here is believe it or not
drink 10 pipe pints and get absolutely
plastered go back home and beat the wife
what
here's the link for a sound clip shout
out to men who don't beat their wives
and children on principle like they did
in the old days
what in the [ __ ] all right open the link
here we go
[Music]
and beat your wife you dirty Northern
bastards so they weren't advocating it
they were calling the other people wife
beaters all right that's fair game
you know
they're not pro-domestic violence
they're actually against it by using it
as an insult I get it you know
I get it
um
you know we all do stupid [ __ ] like that
it was like my wife had the stomach flu
you know and she kept you know getting
sick you know
after a while you just run out of
supportive [ __ ] to say it's like when
somebody keeps sneezing how many times
can you say God bless you my wife the
poor thing kept getting sick and I
didn't know what to do so the last time
she got sick I put on Karen Carpenter I
mean I I panicked I didn't know what to
do looking back I probably shouldn't
have done that but you know
so having a laugh a case for Fahrenheit
hey Billy Bronco hey bronchitis Billy
hey I was pneumonia Williams and
pneumonia
is my hilarious wife said to me uh last
week you were talking about Celsius
being a superior temperature unit well
you said the metric system was Superior
which Celsius isn't part of it's part of
the Centigrade system oh
you know I can't believe I got that
wrong
however as a European I've grown up with
Celsius and think Fahrenheit is way
better here's my case it just Celsius
seems easier to me if water freezes at
zero
and it boils at 100 as opposed to 32 and
I don't even know what it boils at
211 or 212 degrees it's anyway
just seems
I don't know
it just seems easier to me anyway let's
let's see true Celsius is bound to water
but that has nothing to do with how we
experience heat yeah water phrases at
zero Celsius and boils at 100 but so
what my body doesn't
what does that mean
well who's dropping you to a [ __ ] pot
of boiling water you [ __ ]
we're talking about weather
there's going to be [ __ ] way more
days where water is freezing and you get
goddamn snow
you know
that works hope it doesn't get up to 100
Celsius and we're all boiling to death
uh with Fahrenheit it's a scale of zero
to 100 for perceived temperatures for
humans in other words how cold is it
when it's zero degrees Fahrenheit it's
[ __ ] cold
well yeah
that works with Celsius too
how warm is it when it's 100 degrees
Fahrenheit it's [ __ ] hot that's just
because you're familiar with it on a
scale of I mean since I got into
Aviation
I know that when it gets into the 30s uh
uh Celsius I don't want to fly
or at least at altitude I don't want to
[ __ ] do that I don't want to go
anywhere you know I'm not going up to
Big Bear on those days with a full tank
of gas at my big [ __ ] head I ain't
doing that on a scale of zero to a
hundred anything in between is good
enough for us to enjoy
that's not true what 99 degrees is okay
but 100 is it my ideal temperature is 76
degrees Fahrenheit which is 2 4.44
degrees Celsius parentheses stupid that
argument stinks you're just talking
about what you're familiar with
because I was familiar with Fahrenheit
and once I got into Aviation it was
really easy to figure out what it was
going to be like
outside and I never look at Fahrenheit
anymore that's a terrible [ __ ]
argument uh you sound like me when I'm
talking about sports you're glorifying
the 80s with with Fahrenheit
I I disagree with you
and um I don't think you made a good
point in any of that other than
correcting me on whatever the [ __ ] he
said in the beginning and I've already
forgotten what that is all right my best
man came to visit me
uh doesn't bring his wife
who's my cousin
all right let me slow down here your
sister is your brother my best man came
to visit me
doesn't bring his wife
parentheses who's my cousin
okay so your best man married your
cousin all right you don't give a [ __ ]
okay dear badass Billy Burr uh
uh let's see my best friend from back
home in West Virginia
came down to Austin Texas to come spend
New Year's Eve with me and my wife and
kids I haven't seen him since my wedding
which was three years ago so I was
pumped when I picked him up from the
airport it was only him and not his wife
who is my cousin
okay you already sound like you assumed
that he'd be bringing his wife when we
got back to the house I asked him where
she was where she was and said that he
said that they are separated
and things haven't looked up in almost a
year
okay I was shocked because even though
we haven't seen each other in three
years we would stay in contact every
month via text or FaceTime it kind of
bummed me out and put a damper on this
New Year's especially since his wife is
my cousin
since his wife is my cousin dude you've
established this three [ __ ] times and
never and I guess she never mentioned
this anyways
we had a great time together for the few
days till he left okay after he left
I'm really liking this [ __ ] because
I'm trying to guess what's gonna happen
I have no idea I just know something
[ __ ] up is coming
after he left
I have this feeling of being used like a
pawn
to get his mind off of his relationship
which is fine
but am I a selfish prick for being upset
that he didn't tell me and thinking he
only came down here because his marriage
is on the rocks
um
yeah I think you kind of who gives off I
mean who doesn't want to get away from
somebody if they they're
no I think you're being too sensitive
about this this guy texts you and
facetimes you so you guys are friends he
was your best man
at your wedding so you guys are friends
he would have gone to you whether he
married your cousin or not
um I don't know I think you're a little
self-involved there
uh it's got to be devastating to go
through a divorce
somebody you loved you thought you were
going to spend the rest of your life
with and you got to go through that they
say other than losing
a loved one to death the next stressful
thing is going through a divorce so you
know
um yeah dude I wouldn't make this about
you
you kind of acting like a chick here and
you're making this all about you and
just you know I know you're going
through a divorced and everything but
just I was just feeling this don't do
that
all right he said he's a big fan he's
probably not a big fan now because I
just said he was being a douche not
being a douche but you know we all do
that
we all make things about ourselves okay
I made the Bills game about myself today
you know I want to see the Patriots win
that game all right hung in there I
rooted for him I did the right thing the
end of the [ __ ] day I wanted my
teammates like you know where are we all
we all act like that anyway
big fan Bill hope the family is well
let's go Mountaineers all right
I like West Virginia by the way
that's a great state that gets [ __ ]
over by uh
big companies just go in there taking
all the natural resources and they don't
[ __ ] pay anybody it's [ __ ]
terrible beautiful State
uh sticking it to a stuck up hottie
all right here we go okay get ready for
this one everybody
uh hey Billy badass Burr
long time listener first time writing in
I have a funny story I'd like to share
about a time when I rejected a smoking
hot lady lady I think back fondly of
this memory and hopefully it has some
comedic value for you
all right I don't see the value if she
was smoking hot what did she do sir
uh I live in a large Metropolitan you
know we all put up with extra [ __ ]
smoking hot that's what they always say
I mean they always joke about that if
you watch Wheel of Fortune which that
was our show Jeopardy and Wheel of
Fortune we still watch whenever when my
wife
um
was late in her pregnancy and she just
was over it aware a way to just sort of
you know wind down every night was we
would watch those back to back and we'd
have a great time and we would always
laugh because for whatever reason when
you're a contestant on Wheel of Fortune
they would be like who do you got here
today and they always be on my smoking
hot wife
and I think the ladies are my smoking
hot houses always my smoking hot
uh my smile smoking hot wife all right
anyway I live in a large Metropolitan
City in the southwest this town is known
for its partying in Wild nightlife you
could have just said [ __ ] you're in
Arizona
that's what I'm guessing
what is this Scottsdale
huh at the time I was about 22 years old
and I was working as a busser in an
upscale upscale contemporary restaurant
this place was a mad house as you can
imagine from drugs to sexual behavior
rampant among almost all the staff
members and customers
sounds like a reality show if I've ever
heard one
um I'm more of a straight lace kind of
guy in exposure to this kind of
hypersexual hedonistic behaviors always
rub me the wrong way yeah when human
beings start acting like dogs you want
to get away from them that's a good
instinct to have
uh one of the hostesses was a weekend
warrior National Guard
and was a drop dead gorgeous hottie
back in the day she would have been on a
calendar
the [ __ ] smoking hot hotties of the
[ __ ] National Guard in the Southwest
the Playboy guy would have been all over
that uh a 9 out of 10 gorgeous half
Caribbean
Maybe 24.
but she had one of the worst [ __ ]
stuck-up [ __ ] attitudes
well dude she sounds smoking hot already
uh I have I've ever had
he said one of the worst [ __ ] stuck up
[ __ ] attitudes I have ever had to
tolerate
okay I've ever had to tolerate is that
what you mean all right she fit the bill
coked up in a party at him oh I don't do
coked up
I don't do coked up that takes a 10 down
to a [ __ ] minus two see ya uh she
needed to be taken down a Peg and the
Stars aligned
to give me the opportunity organically
why did she need to be taken down a peg
dude that's a waste of energy
just walk away from the wreckage and
just get on with your life but anyway
he's gonna take her down a peg everybody
here we go one night as I was on my way
to work we ended up in a brief
discussion about our college education
you're on your way to work and you guys
were in a brief discussion so you're
commuting
you're riding in the same car I
playfully asked some questions testing
her knowledge of what she had studied
and she said to me why don't we go out
for a few drinks after I get off work
and we can talk about it oh Jesus to
which I replied casually nah I got
better things to do and I'm sure you do
too
the look of shock on her face was
priceless and I walked away feeling like
a badass
uh I know I probably missed out on the
best sexual experience I ever would have
had in my youth but it was worth it
to just for once in my life
to have the willpower to say no to a
beautiful woman parentheses and believe
me I don't get that opportunity often
all right I get this this is kind of
funny uh and she got a taste of her own
medicine to boot I'm nothing special and
probably a jackass but I always think
fondly of that memory oh my God
that reminds me I can't even remember
this story
I was on the road with Joe De Rosa
and there was some smoking hot woman
just at the bar it's back when I drank
and you know running her yap had nothing
to say but she's gorgeous and no one's
telling her to shut up
and we were talking about something
and she said that we were wrong
and
it somehow came down to a bet that if we
could prove that me and Joe are right
versus her she would actually buy a
round
I was really deroza destroyed her I
can't remember how this story went but
somehow she ended up being wrong
and we're like all right for the first
time in your life why don't you buy a
round of drinks Miss cutie pie she goes
I don't think I would [ __ ] will and
she put her credit card down and I don't
know how we figured it out but it was
actually her boyfriend's credit card and
we were able to be like nah nah nah we
made her
we made her put her own credit card down
which she did and she bought us a round
of drinks and when they handed us the
drinks me and Joe promptly turned around
and walked away from her
and we would just I remember we were on
opposite sides
of the bar
laughing our asses off
and I yelled over to DeRosa
I go how does it taste and he did The
Goodfellas he goes delicious delicious
you know when they go over to [ __ ]
Pesci's house they're eating spaghetti
they got Billy bats in the truck
there is something funny about doing
that
um I'm playing she'll survive you know
she's smoking hot she'll forget about it
she probably doesn't even remember it
anyway uh and she actually came around
and wasn't such a cold-hearted [ __ ]
afterward haha to me at least so it all
worked out in the end yeah well there
you go you learned a valuable lesson
uh there's some chicks they're just so
hot
that you almost have to be a dick to him
to kind of Zap them out of like you know
because I think that Taps into the fact
that they kind of know that eventually
their looks are gonna go and they're
really leaning on them so I think that's
a scary moment like oh wait a minute I'm
getting rejected here does this mean
like you know
it's the beginning of the end for me you
know like an athlete the first time you
know you're in the opening and some
young guy runs you down and tackles you
like what the [ __ ] man that was a
touchdown the first 10 years of my
career am I getting slower what's going
on anyway uh she came around
um anyway uh that was many years ago and
I've gotten far away from that
environment I'm not a very good writer
so thanks for hanging in there I thought
you did great
uh uh if you even read this uh you're
one of my heroes Bill and listen to your
podcast and all of your life's advice
you have shared has helped me to become
a better person well I'll give you a
better for next time you [ __ ] with
the half Caribbean [ __ ] cutie pie
uh you already got this story so hang
out with her uh I'd like to thank you
and all your listeners who write in to
ask for advice and share your stories I
have navigated many relationship
pitfalls because of your podcast you're
a gentleman and a scholar sir Jesus
Christ did I write this you're pouring
it on thick uh you are truly doing a
public service thank you I'm also
what is that I I am a public server
right is that what the politicians are
is that what they call each other when
can I get some of those [ __ ] stock
trips that they're getting I have no
idea anyway
um
here's old Billy ball game who couldn't
pick a [ __ ] goddamn rigged fight at
this point
um
uh I I think I I just got a feeling TCU
is gonna win
I don't think they're gonna cover I just
think they're gonna outright win
and for the [ __ ] event I'm gonna put
some money on TCU it's weird I'm gonna
put some money on TCU but I'm gonna be
rooting for Georgia
all right I've liked the Bulldogs since
Herschel Walker okay
and I like the Georgia Bulldogs so much
that I don't give a [ __ ] that Herschel
Walker ran for office and said some
crazy [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] to me
he's he's Herschel Walker
Heisman Trophy winner I believe in his
sophomore season
he's a New Jersey General he's a Dallas
Cowboy he's a Minnesota Viking
right I love how they blamed him because
they had no [ __ ] team up there and
their owner made the worst [ __ ] trade
of all time
um worst [ __ ] trade of all time you
guys ever give you you want to read
about that trade
they traded Herschel Walker for [ __ ]
10 bumps
and everybody thought that the [ __ ]
Vikings got the better part of the deal
but there was a clause in the contract
that if Jimmy Johnson
cut any player he would every player
that he cut he'd get a Minnesota Viking
draft pick
it's the stupidest thing ever so they
signed the deal and then Jimmy looked at
him going you know I'm going to cut all
those players right
they're like Jimmy he wouldn't do that
he goes absolutely I would and he cut
him
he got like [ __ ] 10 draft picks
all right the Vikings stunk they blamed
Herschel Walker and was that goddamn
ownership and then Jimmy Johnson okay
not only does he make the [ __ ] deal
You Know Not only was that shrewd he
then takes those 10 draft picks and I
think he went eight out of 10.
it seemed like probably five of them
were Hall of Famers
he absolutely crushed it and that's what
was the last Dallas Cowboys Dynasty and
now you know the rest of the story all
right that's it everybody
um that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
happy extended New Year everybody uh
let's all have a good one let's be nice
to each other let's not be [ __ ] and
let's hope we all do as well in the
stock market as our Representatives out
there who are public servants right
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll
check in on you on uh uh Thursday